it's not just nancy pelosi joe biden
keeps nominating people to positions of
power who are incredibly radical on the
hard left so for example he has
nominated a person named saul omarova
whose background is literally that she
did a fellowship in moscow while the
soviet union was still standing on
economics and the biden administration
refuses to release the papers that she
did while she was studying over in
moscow because it's pretty obvious that
she has a lot of sympathies toward the
red left
here she was not all that long ago
literally saying she's being nominated
to head up
a banking regulatory agency like a
massive part of the banking regulatory
infrastructure she says you know what we
should work on bankrupting the oil coal
and gas industries
um excuse me you mean how most americans
get their power
and where large swaths of americans are
employed
so this is the person you're nominating
joe biden captain moderation over here
all right
nikki mack will be able the nia will be
able to negotiate equity stakes in
private enterprise that receives that
public aid be it a part of the systemic
bailout or be it part of for example
individualized restructuring help for
example for certain uh troubled
industries and firms that are in
transitioning and here what i'm thinking
about is primarily coal industry and oil
and gas industry a lot of the smaller
players in that industry are
uh going to probably uh go bankrupt in
in in short order at least we want them
to go bankrupt if we want to tackle
climate change right
we want them to go bankrupt because we
want to tackle climate change
who are these people talking to
you still need the power that powers
your house you still need the gas that
powers your car who are these people
talking to who are they talking to
and they're in congress too right you've
got representative ilhanov saying
basically the same thing she's now
trying to get fossil fuel producers to
pay 500 billion dollars for past
greenhouse gas emissions there's only
one problem we all used the carbon-based
fossil fuels that produced the
greenhouse gases
and this is not like
philip morris lying about the effects of
smoking
we we are all well aware that smog is a
product for example of of using gas in
your car okay we are all well aware of
this sort of stuff we all participated
in it we did because and we still
participate in it because guess what
most of us are pretty well-founded in
our belief that human beings will adapt
to a variation in the climate over the
course of a hundred years
but here i mean what is this really
about it's about bankrupting these
industries the same thing in salomon
roma omarova
large bipartisan majority of the united
states public believe that fossil fuel
corporations have a responsibility to
address the dire consequences of their
pollution
the largest fossil fuel producers must
pay for their past
greenhouse gas emissions which could
raise at least 500 billion alone they
must pay for the lives they have taken
for the futures they have robbed and for
the lasting toll their greed will have
on the planet for generations to come
i have a question does she really
believe that if there had been no gas
companies oil and gas companies the
world would be anywhere close to as
wealthy as it is right now
carbon-based fossil fuels are one of the
great discoveries in the history of
mankind raising literally billions of
people from abject poverty in countries
where carbon-based fossil fuels are not
available people are still burning dung
for fuel they're still burning dung and
wood for fuel which is actually really
bad for humans and also not great for
the environment by the way
meanwhile you have commerce secretary
gina raimondo again hostage of the
progressive left i
i'm almost at a loss for words for how
stupid it is that the democrats have
decided to move in this direction i
don't know who is guiding this policy or
why why they refuse to triangulate to
the middle
listen i'm i'm a person of the right and
i would much prefer to see the democrats
continue to embrace the suck and then
lose because of it like do it really go
as woke as you want go as radically
environmentalist as you want i'm just
bemused as a political observer and
someone who's done this professionally
for 20 years to watch joe biden a man
who's elected in the teeth of bernie
sanders a man who was elected to
deliberately push back against the
radical left embrace the entire agenda
of the radical left like i don't know
what's
the answer maybe is that there's not a
lot knocking around in that brain these
days
and there's uh that is an empty room
with a lot of cobwebs upstairs that
attic is is definitely not full there
are a few ghouls hanging around up there
anyway gina raimondo
who's the commerce secretary
is continuing to push this sort of
nonsense equity is at the center of
everything we do okay so this is the
coded
racial equity language the ibramex candy
language pushed by the radical
progressive left
broadband is the gateway to economic
opportunity and so in order to open that
gateway we're putting equity at the
center of everything we do
i will say
to truly transform our economy into one
that works for all americans and one
that will make our country more
competitive on the world stage
we have to make investments in a way
that is equitable and just
and we view this lens across all of the
work we do at the commerce department
and it will be particularly front and
center with the broadband work that we
will be doing
broadband equity
broadband equity okay meanwhile the
biden administration has now nominated a
progressive partisan named gigi sone to
the federal communications commission
this is according to the wall street
journal the white house last month
hailed son as one of the nation's
leading public advocates for open
affordable and democratic communications
networks translation she favors
deploying the agency's regulatory power
to shackle broadband providers in
silence conservative voices
miss sohn founded the left-wing group
public knowledge that has long sought
more government control of the internet
and media she was a counselor to obama
fcc chair tom wheeler and was a driving
force behind net neutrality regulation
that classified broadband providers as
common carriers under title ii of the
communications act of 1934
the wheeler rule banned broadband
carriers from charging heavy band with
consuming websites like netflix and
facebook more to carry their content
she's also hinted at deploying the
agency's regulatory power to censor
conservative media she tweeted in
october of last year quote for all my
concerns about facebook i believe fox
news has had the most negative impact on
our democracy it is state-sponsored
propaganda with few if any opposing
viewpoints
she has suggested using the fcc power
over broadcast licenses to censor
conservative outlets
after tribune broadcasting abandoned its
merger with sinclair broadcast in 2018
she said today is a good day for every
american who believes that diverse's
avoid diversity of voices in the media
is better for our democracy and urged
the fcc to look at whether sinclair is
qualified to be a broadcast licensee at
all
the fcc is split 2-2 if so is confirmed
democrats will quickly move on the
progressive agenda
i mean it's it's just it's incredible so
they're embracing a hard leftism in
every single form
and they're not hiding the ball about it
either
again this is being driven by an elite
progressive left
and the agenda is is not unclear and
jamel bowie makes the agenda
particularly clear today he has a piece
in the new york times called what
structural racism really means and what
he actually concludes is the only way to
fight structural racism is not to fight
racism per se is to dismantle all of the
institutions of society
he says quote racism does not survive in
the main because of personal belief and
prejudice it survives because it is
inscribed and re-inscribed by the
relationships and dynamics that
structure our society from segregation
and exclusion to inequality and
degradation of labor
right so capitalism has to go
the meritocracy has to go
jamel bowie writes the solution as the
reverend dr martin luther king jr wrote
in his year in the year of his
assassination must involve a revolution
of values that will look uneasily on the
glaring contrast of poverty and wealth
and see that an edifice which produces
beggars needs restructuring
if democracy is to have meaning king
declared it is necessary to adjust this
inequity it is not only moral but it is
also intelligent we are wasting and
degrading human life by clinging to
archaic thinking by archaic thinking
jamel bowie quoting dr martin luther
king jr there
is means capitalism and free markets
he says there's an inextricable link
between all the things that make your
life good and racism and inequity and
evil
this is the group of people that the
democratic party is now hostage to the
progressive left we'll get some more of
this in just one second because really
it is elite
it is an elite group of people who have
benefited from the system and now are
looking down on the system and spitting
at it because the vast majority of
people who are living in moderate
circumstances in the united states
middle to low income in the united
states are not on board with this crap
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed